morning vlog
[Music]
last night i was recruiting a a guy for
uh vaynersports so i had to set an alarm
because i was an event in chattanooga
and uh and then i didn't realize it was
still on pm so i set my alarm so this
morning i woke up
um just randomly i actually think it was
a skip
in my sound machine from a call
potentially that i like
woke up and i look at my i knew i was in
trouble
because the alarm didn't go off and i
grabbed my phone it was 509 i have a 6am
flight
and and
made it chattanooga airport you have to
like cruise through is it pretty
you know what's crazy i got i i was in
the car by like 5 15.
yeah and it's 15 minutes 5 30 and i was
like okay i can get through it in four
minutes
and i'll be good because as long as
you're there 10 minutes before
i got there and the line was massive and
like literally four people were like
this is the longest i've ever seen in
the history of the chattanooga airport
so i caught people it was very nice of
people i was like please
and uh and then still it took forever
but then
i got there it was like 5 50 and they
still haven't boarded the plane
that was good good stuff we made it alex
how do we we may need to create a
separate situation where it's hotter
i don't know what to do maybe in here or
you know something to think about
can you investigate
go call me yeah it's not about that yeah
i'm also on the verge of potentially
getting sick provided
by the way i was 100 i should be super
sick right now my mental breakthrough
i haven't i've slept like six hours in
two days i'm like i'm a mess right now
and i i woke up and like was should have
been dead
i can't believe how i feel right now the
brain is so underrated marcus
there's also something around like a lot
of corporations are moving to this like
entrepreneur
type of like mentality like trying to
get their teams to think
more small and start products on their
own
so i think there would be value in like
meeting almost like org structure yeah
exactly i want to make i want to make i
want to make a video rant
today about this entrepreneur subject
and i wanted to start
with kim just saying that naturally and
i'm going to segue into my rant i've
been wanting to talk about this
and that'll be cool and it's just time
because i'll just make my rant right now
which is
there is no [ __ ] entrepreneurs in
these companies they don't create the
framework
for an entrepreneur it's like being a
cfo at vaynermedia
there's no framework for it like yeah it
sucks or like be an entrepreneur but
then all your bonuses are
predicated on the internal mmm hitting
the four dollar cpm on program
anyway
[Music]
episode 262 ryan holiday
you guys were talking about marketing
talking about all that stuff i'm
in my new apartment and painting my new
apartment and you said something about
documenting versus
that was like bam i was like this guy's
on to something
so on confidence just just as an
encouragement to when you talk like how
people react and what they listen what
they do about it
i was like i'm gonna work there for for
whatever time
is gonna be i'm gonna work there and
that was august 10th
august 22nd i was on the phone with
cecilia just like it was one of those
things i was like good for you brother
it's awesome if this guy's talking about
let's do something about it let's really
do something about it so you know
encouragement to you that people thank
you are listening the other thing i
wanted to talk about is parenting
yes i think i'm on to something when it
comes to dads and fitness
interesting i have an idea that i want
to start pretty soon
from your perspective i know the tools
that i need i know the information that
i want to put it out
what's the best how do you choose the
best platform to start
can you do a podcast yes i can
the answer is 100 that that's fine i'm
gonna write down
big letters yeah it's funny that you
said that because there's nothing else
to say brother
yeah can i tell you why it's passive
consumption
yeah and it's still you know how i think
about all this stuff
like real estate sure podcast is on the
third street
off the beach right now yeah yeah social
media is on the
other side like 29 streets in yeah yeah
right yeah
yeah yeah and ar or crypto are on the
beach right now right you understand
yeah i like the third because the
problem with being on the beach
is you're pumped when it's malibu yeah
but you lose a [ __ ] load of money when
it's
malibu yeah got it do you understand
yeah
podcasting yeah it was great meeting you
man such a pleasure
uh vlog i'm going to do something fun
right now
uh you can get in here justin to vlog
uh leave a comment and say i want the
book and you will get one of the proof
copies
i'm going to put it here until we send
it and that's that
i'm doing doubles no team around me run
deep i gotta hustle
i'm beating all these eyes see the
bruises on my knuckles and through these
hard times i'm talking to them
quick take i'm gonna give you my quick
opinions on things on the blog right now
just coming through the wire facebook
adds a snooze button
which lets you uh i guess snooze people
out facebook adds a snooze button for
muting people groups and pages for 30
days
today is launching a new feature
designed to give users more control
i've been saying it forever everyone's
like facebook makes me do this facebook
screws me
that facebook's only value is your
attention and they will always make the
best product
for you and they will continue to do
things for you for you to stay inside of
facebook and instagram
your attention is facebook's product
that they
sell they're very smart and don't take
it for granted
and actually give a [ __ ] about you from
a macro because it's in it for them
and that's why that product will
continue to be awesome facebook and
amazon
do things for you that are then for them
it's kind of like how i think about it
nonetheless a very interesting feature
that once again
proves it's for facebook to do the
things
that you want and that's how they'll win
and that is the
always that is always the best strategy
which is be consumer-centric
and you will have the leverage good job
facebook another little micro headline
little feature that may not be
understood in the macro
which is do it for the consumer
and the consumer's admiration spend
attention will give you the leverage for
what you're
trying to accomplish you want some real
advice
like real yeah you if you guys
understood
that you could accomplish nothing for
the next eight years and i mean zero
and still be young as [ __ ] and like
dominate life you would get on a plane
and spend the next two years going
everywhere
because there's no downside and there's
nothing but upside
down yeah i mean everybody's got
everybody everybody is playing their 20s
backwards
everybody's got such a chip on their
shoulder between debt or to prove to
somebody that they've got something
that they go right into dumb [ __ ] to
start getting short money
and like do the right thing or prove
something
they need to punt everybody should
[ __ ] the 22 to 30 year old
play should be even more ridiculous than
18 to 22
and one day i think it will be i think
22 to 30 is gonna get real [ __ ] fun
i'm pissed that i'm gonna miss it i
think you people should [ __ ] punt it
i think you guys should [ __ ]
go around the world as a horde live in
shitty places like
learn taste play a hundred percent
i just wanted to show you something
really cool do you like magic yeah i
mean i've been getting magic done like
by all these instagram and and you i
think you know what's funny
you know what's funny i really like
magic
i now really understand what the [ __ ]
people are doing it's actually what i do
which is what i like about magic is it's
manipulation of attention
like i did not know how you what you're
about to do
i did not know how you did it a year ago
i know exactly what you're about to do
and now what's happening is when people
do magic on me i'm looking at
nothing that they want me to look at and
i'm trying to guess what they're
actually doing
and the last time dude did magic on me
that's like this big instagrammer it was
[ __ ] for me because i could see
everything he was doing
though a year ago i would have been like
what the [ __ ]
who was who was the one doing magic i
don't know crazy
the first guy you tell by not julian i
mean david blaine's a good friend of
mine right
and so like that [ __ ] was like when i
didn't know what the magicians were
doing
and he's so good it was like [ __ ] me
right
but now i actually i'm actually gonna
get drinks with him soon because now i'm
excited to see how good he is at his
craft
because i will it's so crazy you're
probably the first guy that's tried to
do this to me since i've completely
cemented
the last time dude did magic on me oh at
the soccer thing
yeah i it was the craziest thing now
again this guy is really considered good
because i looked into it
and i and i could see what he was doing
and it's interesting because it's what i
think i do as a person
i live my life the way magicians run
their world which is
it seems like i'm doing something to you
but i'm doing something else and i'm
trying to teach everybody that's what
i'm doing
so that you guys can do it too i wish
you could see the i'm getting i'm
getting goosebumps right now
the last time the time before that i s i
it clicked
so when he came dude in london
or whatever amsterdam uh sweden i was
like ready
and the reason i'm telling you is now i
was so ready it was crazy i could have
really blew up dude spot
and i held off because i'm like i wanted
to respect the game
now it's going to be a funny game when
magicians try to do [ __ ] to me
of how fast and good are they at that
thing
because i'm not looking at the thing
that they want me to look at anymore
you ready i'm ready with all that
all right no pressure it's fine we're
just gonna have fun
he's one of the top guys at the magic
castle i believe you i
i just thought i would i just really
wanted to tell him that because it blew
my mind
it's interesting right it's an
interesting way to articulate it right
it's true it was
really interesting and now i'm like into
it all right go ahead
um all right deck of cards yes
i want you you're going to stop me at
any card you like whatever card
go for it stop there good we're gonna
put that card let's put it right there
you're not gonna look at it i'm not
gonna look at it we're gonna put this
bottle right on top of it all right my
job is to find every card that's
related to that card okay for example if
you have like the three of diamonds yes
hearts clubs and spades it's my job to
get out
okay without you knowing the card so
that's what we're gonna do
let's do
i don't think any of those are your card
actually the first one comes to the top
like that you see that i know you saw
that it
kind of popped up there's a heart which
is interesting we'll put that down right
there can you hold your hands out
because the magic is gonna happen in
your hands right here
i'm going to go like like that
right there now let's take a look
the next card goes on top
take a look at it is that another ace it
sure is is that this okay so it's not uh
that one it said was the first one was
the heart or the heart it was the heart
okay put that one down there hold your
hands out
okay we'll go one two three
let's see so now i have to kind of i
kind of have to look and assess the
situation see what i got here let's give
it a few shuffles like that
remember how you said stop at the
beginning yes you're gonna say stop
again whenever you like
stop right there take a look at that
card right there the ace of clubs i love
it
you're the magician not me but what's
interesting is what first of all
ninety percent of what's happened so far
i have no [ __ ] idea
that one i understood i never would have
before
because i was looking at something it's
super cool it's
super cool it's sun it it actually
you'll find this interesting
i actually now want to have this talent
whereas before i didn't even think about
it
because it's a real skill it's it's
there's two different things going on
the skill
of like being able to maneuver [ __ ] and
then the skill of storytelling and all
the other stuff
yeah like i know exactly what that is
you know and like to me
that's the ace of spades
you know like like oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i'm sorry those are the things
that's what's up man that's what's up
to me that will forever honestly that is
so [ __ ] gangster
i have so much respect for that
and i'm so grateful that that is what
i'm actually doing in life with my life
literally that's a good for you thank
you dude that was so badass thank you
thank you that was so good
so good and i i made it so much better
by talking so bright
i made it so much better i gotta go see
him no problem all right guys take care
of yourself take it easy gary thank you
hello new york and welcome to the very
first episode of new york city pulse a
brand new show that dives deep into the
mindset of new yorkers with relentless
drive
in pursuit of their ambition and our
very first guest today absolutely
exemplifies this description
the man sitting next to me here is the
one and only gary
vaynerchuk i know you have siblings yes
younger siblings
right um so with your father's absence
yes most of the time did that force you
to step up at home 100
like a leadership 100 i think it's a
good observation that don't people don't
i'm already optimistic for your show
because i think that's a good
observation
that i don't remember a lot of people
asking me um
that's exactly right i mean me and my
mom are only 20 years apart
so when i was 14 she was 34. like justin
how old are you
justin's 21 i'm 42 my mom was
i'm older than my mom like our gap is
bigger than me and my mom
and we i don't i feel like we're
contemporaries he doesn't feel like
we're contemporaries but he doesn't
think i'm as
old as i actually am compared to him
given like my vibe but like
that's how my mom was right like no she
was my mom but we were like yeah she was
34 i was 14 and we were like my dad
wasn't around so like
you know i babysat the kids and i like
set the tone and like i was a leader in
my house from the get for sure
and that definitely paved the road for
you to be an effective leader 100
a hundred thousand percent i think
that's a very astute
observation that a lot of people have
not made i listen by watching what
people do
like i already know what sneakers he's
wearing right i'm paying attention to
how you're wearing your hair
i mean yeah what do you think i think
it's different okay i think i
and i think i think it's kind of like
fez from the 70s show
i think it's a throwback and honestly i
took
i took note of that i'm like what does
that mean
i like that [ __ ] so i i've learned how
to listen
without talking excuse me i've learned
how to listen without the other person
talking
my whole life that's how you do sales
you know i used to do baseball card
shows i would stand by a table
he would walk table to table table and
he would look at my cards he would not
say anything because he's a shopper
can i help you i'd say can i help you
and he'd say no well i could have
checked out and been lazy
but i wasn't i would then spend my time
looking at him without being creepy i'd
like
kind of like look and be like let me
know if i can help you with anything i
would watch
and watch what he would look at what
made him buy why
who then i'd watch him in the table if
he went to the left and right see what
he did there
i learned how to then i did retail just
to behind a register all day and just
would watch people so i watch right but
that's that's in person sales but now
you're leading a much bigger company and
you're not you don't have that ability
to
watch other people yeah but guess what
once you have that seed you understand
how to scale it
got it here's the part that i have that
is i figured out is a magic
magic no expectation of others
i do great by him i do great by him i do
great by him i eat his [ __ ] i do great i
do great i do great
then he goes does something something
good happens he can help me and he
doesn't
for some weird reason i don't give a
[ __ ]
and so many people get crippled when
they so many people do not
very little and expect like you know
most people give with expectation
yes the [ __ ] am i getting out of this
nothing
thank you for doing this i mean this is
your first [ __ ] show nine people are
gonna watch
that's right but now but now you're
gonna have
do you know what your guests are gonna
look like now you're gonna go and
[ __ ] say gary vaynerchuk was my first
[ __ ] guess you're gonna get
10 times the quality guests you would
have gotten you're gonna get
guest number four of this show is the
quality of the guest that would have
been guest 147
right just by me allocating these 15
minutes
and that's again an example of giving
without expecting in return
that's right and if you go on to become
larry king and i need to promote
some [ __ ] in 21 years who has you
or not and this is the key that'd be
great and i hope so and surely i think
about that
but if you said no through your booker
i would never say i would i would say to
the tyler i would say to my admin i
would say
that's some [ __ ] i'd be like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you know
but i would never be deaf that would be
the extent of it would be like that
[ __ ] kid that [ __ ] kid would be
nowhere if i didn't do the first [ __ ]
that which i wouldn't believe by the way
because if somebody gets somewhere
you might have been part of their path
but i don't you know maybe i accelerated
it but we all accelerate each other
maybe i wouldn't be where i was if
justin didn't make a video like there's
a million what-ifs here's what i would
say for some reason after about a minute
of being like [ __ ] that kid
i hope his show gets cancelled you know
like competitive [ __ ]
i'd be like maybe he's in a bad place
maybe he's going through a divorce maybe
he forgot maybe
maybe he thinks about it differently
than i did i have empathy man
empathy is a powerful drug so at 19 you
probably had some vision of what your
life would look like
at 42 right yeah so how does
what has actually happened compared to
that vision that you had when you were
19.
are you there did you meet it i don't
live i don't live in the suburbs i've
thought that uh
i can't see anything else i knew i'd be
successful
like really successfully that and the
fact that i was already successful at 19
sun
toys and baseball cards and like i was
dude
i wish i was documenting my whole life
you know like like people don't know my
true story
meaning people hear the story i went
into my dad's business and did 3 million
immediately when you hear that statement
you're like dad put him on
people don't know that i you know built
my dad's business for him and left
wine library 34 with nothing inequity in
that company
right people don't know that like i
never paid myself that much money
so i had not that much money people
don't know what it looks like to have no
money and make three thousand dollars a
weekend
pre-internet as a 15 year old in 1990
that's what i did with no [ __ ] money
[ __ ]
i went traded with kids made good trades
went to a baseball card show
sold some saved my 80 bucks bought more
stuff like
it takes talent to make three thousand
you know me 99
of your audience doesn't know how to
make 3 000 a week i did have 15 with no
[ __ ] money
so i knew i was [ __ ] all time
from the get from the [ __ ] get you
know what i was doing at 19 i was
calling my mom at college
crying saying i don't want to go into
the family business even though i want
to help
because one day everybody will hold that
over me and say that i was given
something
that's why i don't own anything in wine
library ultimately i never wanted
anything because i don't want anybody
have any excuse not to chase their dream
and work [ __ ] hard
because i knew i'd be the greatest
example of it of all time and i didn't
want them to have something on me
i want people to understand like if
you're good enough you will win
you have to be patient you have to put
in the work
if this show is going to be big it will
be big
you just got to put in the work and put
deploy the patience let's go rapid fire
around
rapid fire okay i'll go faster yes um
let's talk
legacy yes okay uh
don't want to die you don't want to talk
about it i'll talk about it i
desperately don't want to die so look
you seem like the type of person who
wants to be in control of everything yes
so now if you had the luxury of being
able to control
yes when you'd go yes in a perfect world
yes when would that be when you
nine after you accomplish something when
you're i could go tomorrow from a
no no no no no it's not about it's not
about
putting points on the board that's
already done
when i made a hundred thousand dollars a
year that was my only weird thing on the
board
yes i want to buy the jobs yeah yes i
want to buy the jets
but i want to try to buy the jets more
than getting you know
the thrill of the chase more than the
right
um i just want to live forever
it's fun the [ __ ] do i want to die for
i'm going to be immortal yeah yeah but
if you had to put a number on it i don't
know of nine billion
fine maybe i'll get mad when i get up
there and said i wish i did 88 billion
but like
nine billion's fine final question gary
um
fill in this blank gary vaynerchuk
is the greatest the greatest
and with that we wrap up i have to i
have to preface it because muhammad ali
actually took it and he deserves it and
should stay there
gary vaynerchuk was the
disproportionate best entrepreneur
of a generation in in
helping the other entrepreneurs while he
was getting his
got it gary vaynerchuk can agree to that
was the best
entrepreneur in helping other
entrepreneurs
while getting his so doesn't mean i'm
going to make the most money
doesn't mean i'm going to be elon musk
or you know zucks or
you know bezos the most right or the
most iconic and change the game elon
things like that
doesn't mean that i was like open like
like just like an author that helped a
lot of people
or you know or oprah or tony robbins
right
i was the best at building the biggest
thing and trying to
drag everybody with me because i didn't
think
any of their success came at my expense
this nobody that will look like me ever
would ever do this interview right ever
it's the legacy that you're after ever
ever ever ever you understand yeah
nobody who's going to end up
as big of a winner as i am would have
ever done this interview that is my
legacy
so it's cooking same all you know uh
some good stuff i think i was here maybe
nine months ago yep and i got
tired and josh is really starting to
he's been following you forever but
we're doing your playlist when i gotta
tell you this
it matters it's [ __ ] is working no [ __ ]
and but
it's and and when you're smart enough to
hire somebody
who is following my stuff it speeds up
the learning curve
a lot of people are going to go out
right who are watching right now and go
hire
just a video kid and they're gonna say
go watch garyvee i gave him every book
how long did you consume my stuff before
um
right it was big like justin was like
further because because there's nuances
in my [ __ ]
and it's way more nuanced than you can
think you can ask him it's even crazier
and
it's crazier or good in real life no
it's not about
it's not that it's uh it's not about
like success or
or skills or scale it's about
doing the right thing i think my whole
thing is so fundamentally
uh strong because it's not selfish
yeah good to see you as always
thank you sir so nice to meet you take
care way they're gonna get it right
period that's [ __ ] awesome
good right i think you got something
somebody has to step up in this company
or we have to hire somebody
to do that [ __ ] 24 7. i'm so fired up
i'm now start
what we're doing doesn't work what we're
gonna do is whether
justin decides he wants to do this or
seth or we hire somebody the call to
action is very simple
your [ __ ] life for next year is to be
great at that
prove it to like we're gonna actually we
just did it [ __ ] it chop this up i want
to tweet it
you guys see the [ __ ] like [ __ ] you i
want you to edit it because you
understand what i'm saying
if you can make these things show the
six or seven that work
if you have the [ __ ] discipline to
[ __ ] eat [ __ ] for two years on my
team for dick [ __ ] money
and look through all my [ __ ] content
over the last two years especially the
last year
because there's nothing but [ __ ]
jewels and [ __ ] facts
everywhere that you've never seen
because we cut we can't [ __ ] find
them
we [ __ ] let them go like [ __ ] like
now we got something from no jumper
no when we come back people are working
on dailyvee in this set but you [ __ ]
think it's great to watch 18 [ __ ]
hours of footage
seven hours of footage you live for you
live for watching that content
and finding the seven little [ __ ]
minutes and making this micro [ __ ]
content
for snapchat and twitter and facebook
and instagram these one minute [ __ ]
memes
that [ __ ] are straight fire that are
so magic if you want to eat [ __ ] and you
think you're great at it
submit right here i have no idea what
we're going to call it you're going to
make a google form
it's going to be linked in all the
things there's the url gary b-e-e
i can do it that's what it is
garyvee.com
i can do it go make the google form now
submit your version of it [ __ ] strip
the videos
off the [ __ ] youtubes and [ __ ] go to
viddler if you're a gangster do your
thing
make the [ __ ] video and submit it
don't waste your time if your dog [ __ ]
cause drock's gonna throw
up on it if you've got this [ __ ]
skill
go [ __ ] make one and i'll see you
february first at vaynermedia i'm gonna
hire two or three of you [ __ ]
if you could actually do it no question
for me
the thought of entering the chinese
market
in a meaningful way around my thoughts
my dreams my aspirations the content
obviously you're aware of it but i agree
99.9999999999
of people don't in china and obviously
for me
you know china you know is such a big
part of my future
over the next 50 years and so as you
know
a couple you know about a year and a
half ago i started converting some of my
content
into mandarin and things of that nature
i've you know i produce profiles on some
of the bigger platforms weibo and things
of that nature
uh obviously you know i've spent no time
in asia prior to 2017.
i've been in singapore and hong kong
next year i'll be in mainland china
twice
i think 20. 2019 2020
i think i'm gonna come very hard and so
uh
and this is part of that and so i'm very
excited i can't wait to meet so many of
you
uh whether in new york or london or
china or beijing so i can't wait
so who are some of the greatest
communicators that you ever met
i know perhaps singling someone is hard
for you but
i'd love to know who you think about
it's a great question um larry king
larry king interviewed me he's 80
something years old
i was blown away by how good he was
blown away larry king is very high up
for me
um who i've met
uh nipsy hustle the rapper
he's so thoughtful about the way he
produces his songs
and he paints such a clear picture of
his truth
uh he stands out for me um
uh i think tim ferriss is an incredibly
strong communicator
i think he's very self-aware about what
he's good at
uh and i think he does a very good job
of communicating in his way
joe rogan i think joe rogan's podcast is
very successful because he's such a good
communicator
the mix between the way he interviews
and talks
i'm not as good at that because i talk
over my guests he has the right balance
of
letting them breathe but also getting in
his um
so those are some people that stand out
listen here's what i here's my advice
for men women and everything in between
the truth is undefeated i've been saying
it for a very long time
there's no hiding the gig is up
so and that's my advice for everybody
about everything forever
so that's my advice for a dirty old man
in america that's my advice long term
for china around tiananmen square
that's my advice about everything the
truth
in the long term is undefeated
if you do the wrong thing you will lose
but you know
i know i'm american but it's the same
way i think about
an african-american or a female or a
latino girl like
i just think it's meritocracy and
capitalism and playing the game like
i would never of course i think women
are going to be
a bigger impact it's because the old
rules didn't let them get the fair
amount of impact
they're 100 equal they have different
dynamics a lot of women
you know men don't give birth to
children so they don't have that
variable
so we are different but we're the same
you know so yeah i you know i don't even
think of it that way i'm excited
that the world is getting transparent
uh i think a lot of people are not and i
think a lot of people are scared of a
transparent world
including america including china
and russia like china russia and america
are not going to let blockchain get too
big
new college grads patience everybody's
so impatient
especially in the asian markets you have
to prove something to your parents so
much
that you go so fast and so hard just to
get that chip off your shoulder
either to pay them back and you want to
do good for them or
because you're actually mad at them and
you want to stick it to them and so you
start making fast
short-term decisions in your 20s of what
you're supposed to do
and it screws you up for the long term
thank you so much you did a great job
of course you did a great job heading
out voices shot
good day
[Music]
you